I know I hey haha gon run hi and welcome
to stupid intro Shack oh [ __ ]
anyway I want to yeah I words so I had a
really busy day it's kind of late it's
already 10:00 and I should have done
this video hours ago we're gonna do a QA
Brian to your questions does that sound
good
go can you lick the bottom of your foot
while spanking an apple I hope mine says
parents doesn't walk in right now it
would be hard to explain
yeah I hope my mom is watching this and
is really proud of my next question to
you hello Scott
kill kill kiss kill or marry Justin
Bieber honey boo boo child's mom or Lady
gaga
well I [ __ ] love Lady Gaga so I'll
guess I'll kill her and then I add
Justin Bieber I would marry because Yolo
am i right oh I would kiss honey boo boo
child mom just because to see if I
survive next question what are you
wearing
why don't you come here and find out
next question what do you think about
Ian and Anthony from Smosh before I
really knew Smosh I thought they were
kind of idiots and now that I know them
I know they're idiots
next question Oh get it Ian and Anthony
are really cool people next question
their pills what happened with your hair
urn next question you woke up as a woman
what would be the first thing that you
would do
I probably fat girls can't really fat
can they [ __ ] well I'm out of ideas
next question why are you such a genius
duck don't go there don't go that Russ
next question when you first found you
were a dot next question do you have any
special powers like patting your head
while rubbing your belly I know I can
there we go Valek normal all right yes
and I can also link my tongue lick my
tongue belly pit ah next question do you
do a staring competition with me are you
ready Braz but pretty icy out there I
like it
my eyes are starting to burn Oh Bravo
bro you won and you made me cry if you
didn't win you have to be honest about
next question can you give me a good and
catchy name to my youtube channel
dragon skater of fabulousness 1969 BAM 1
million for a subscriber next question
do you have any other nicknames than
PewDiePie pewdie or kids my mom used to
call me Felicia
next question why do I do blue because
you eat Smurfs next question why can't
we be friends why can't we be firm be
cuz you don't sing good enough I'm
kidding you can be my friend next
question besides YouTube what is your
greatest achievement
probably getting into my first choice of
university next question what is your
favorite film I used to say it was Taco
doors but right now I think is Donnie
Darko it's a really good movie a genius
move
I keep thinking about it and I'm like ah
it's so good
Oh next question your opinion on big
nipples I don't know if they want to be
big that's okay that's okay with me you
know I'm not but I don't want to be a
racist next question what career would
you pursue if your YouTube career fail
which I highlight guide um I don't
really see YouTube as a career it's more
like something that I like doing um but
if it fails I am sure that I will be a
really great horse
next question have you ever recorded a
video I thought that didn't go so well
my fans deserve better yes for sure I do
that a lot but I feel I feel like every
youtuber has not that it's more or less
for each person I think next question
you could only wear one color for the
rest of light pink next question
anyway that was all for today bros again
thank you so much for all the support I
I felt I don't deserve it and I'm really
don't but thank you anyway I I'm just
really happy it really means a lot to me
cute keep being awesome bros and I'll
promise I'll keep making videos is that
a deal is that a deal that I hear yes
I can't hear on this kid I don't want to
be like that hey let's let's let's
change it up and give her a gift through
a hug instead yeah that's not gonna work
how about this if you ever see me and
realize you are free to give me a not a
deal
all right that's much my next question
come on activate